[Musique]
or le village de monpazier a été
construit vous en viendrez 14e siècle ça
fait fouillis la roulade installé ici et
les gens étaient cartonné là devant la
devant vous la ici sur cette passe se
verrait une époque très rude un très
très difficile quand même aux aides
était un spectacle
le match aurait été cruel pour l'homme
très cruel il l'est toujours autant
s'est pas améliorée toutes les rues se
croisent angle droit comme new york les
petites rues sont appelés dès kaeru
regarder si ces bosses tu es super chez
carglass et république
regardez ces génies du attrait l'oaci là
nous sommes dans les coulisses du
village elle et ses vieux murs ils ont
vu croyez moi puisque je suis un enfant
j'adore me faire peur ça c'est certain
superbe de serre peur
ce que j'aurais aimé cette époque c'est
le temps nous vivons dans le siècle de
la vitesse c'est à dire que chaque année
nous avons un petit peu plus vite que
l'année d'avant
regardez c'est beau la pendule c'est
quand même une grande partie de notre
vie rappelez vous ces films où le trésor
de la vieille et cachés dans le meuble
de l'horloge et belle comtoise comme ça
oui c'est pas marrant ça suffit qu'ils
tapent sur la cote
regardez les les deux colombes autour de
la pendule de serre ont quand même la
peine d'être vue je sais qu'il était
très de mode à une époque dans notre
métier notamment que certaines vedettes
se permettent d'arriver à n'importe quel
je n'ai jamais supporté
je suis extrêmement ponctuels je n'ai
pas peur du temps je vis totalement avec
je ne dis pas encore un jour de passer
encore un genre qui me rapproche de ma
faim ce qui est mathématique mais je n'y
pense pas du tout vaut mieux parce que
je suis critique
[Musique]
comment adapter qui tient la caméra ça
marche hélas la campagne instantanée les
lieux m'a tout de suite emballé
j'ai vécu 35 ans sur la mer j'ai avant
tout été un marin bon dans la vie
lorsque j'ai je n'ai plus des capable
j'ai cherché un lieu de grands espaces
une grande pureté dans les styles dans
les constructions et puis le moyen de se
perdre dans des éléments qui paraissent
toujours les mêmes et qui sont pourtant
tout le temps différent
vous êtes venus pour voir ma collection
d'art populaire bien sûr voilà une
chaufferette le remettez le charbon que
le petit réceptacle à l'intérieur et on
se mettait les pieds au dessus et
d'autre du rhin matraque fait en fanon
de baleines france est ingrate dos avec
la petite main pour se gratter le doux
très très pratique si vous n'êtes pas
sages me ferai un plaisir de vous tirer
dessus avec ce très joli pistonné quel
objet vous aimeriez être réincarné
si c'est pour demeurer entre les mains
de mes enfants peut-être qu'un couteau
serait une bonne idée parce qu'on s'en
sert tous les jours je découpe convives
tech avec tapas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai la passion des vieilles pierres et
avec ma femme nous avons trois maisons
et c'est donc une autre activité de
loueur de maisons de vacances
comme je suis un peu commerce henry
fonda le téléachat la télé tout le monde
le sait je m'entends bien avec ce
profession que ça va
il ya dans chaque maison quelques livre
d'un auteur excellent je suppute qu'il
me manque un peu de péter pas mais bon
c'est presqu'à fait pour ça
[Musique]